from the very beginning Google's Nexus
phones have been all about developers
there super fast phones designed to show
the newest and greatest of what Google
can do oh and they were ugly but this
year's different the Nexus 6p and 5x are
designed with Huawei and LG to be
flat-out great phones they do still sort
with software though both phones run the
latest version of Android which is
called marshmallow marshmallow is mostly
designed around little things that make
your phone easier to use and easier to
understand the biggest thing feature is
called now on tagged basically now on
tap is designed to give you up to the
moment information about whatever you're
doing at the moment so say you're
texting your friend about a restaurant
you want to go to you just long press on
the home button and it'll show you maybe
the phone number for that restaurant or
an open table link so you can make a
reservation it's really amazing when it
works but most of the time it doesn't
work a lot of times you'll get something
totally random on the screen or nothing
at all now on tap is going to be a great
feature but it's really not yet in
general Android is a fantastic operating
system but it still falls short in one
key place the apps just aren't as good
as they are on the iPhone that's the
thing about these phones that's what
they're made for Google and Huawei and
LG did the absolute best that they could
and now it's actually up to developers
ok so the phones themselves the 499 6p
is very much the flagship phone here it
is abby's and it behaves like one it is
a 5.7 inch screen which is a little
smaller but so much easier to use than
the gigantic Nexus 6 it lasts a full day
of battery too despite the super high
res screen and super powerful process
and the 5x is still good but slightly
less impressive for 379 dollars you get
a slightly smaller 5.2 inch screen you
get a slightly older but still very fast
processor and you get slightly less
battery life just because the thing is
it's not as polished and handsome as the
6p but it's a very good fun whichever
one of these you buy you get the same
awesome twelve point three megapixel
camera on the back that is as good as
any smartphone on the planet you also
get the super fast fingerprint reader on
the back which will take you several
days to get used to and you'll keep
hitting the button on the front thinking
that it's not a speaker but a
fingerprint reader and you'll also get
the USB type-c charger which exists on
the bottom it charges so fast and it's
so useful but good luck finding a
replacement until they're more these out
there these phones in most ways are the
same but the 6 p's better in fact the 6p
might be the best android phone ever
made you know what it might be the best
phone ever made if it weren't for the
app and that's the thing google has done
its part here it built a killer phone
with killer software now developers need
to get on board and make something
worthy of this